all right so when I think of things that
we drink - I think of celebrations right
yeah that's me is that what this album
is about what tell me all about it
yeah man I mean it's about my life over
the last few years or the few years
prior to releasing it at least and
there's a lot to celebrate
I moved from Australia to Nashville
which is the other side of the world
it's a big deal for me and I got to put
out my first music here I also met a
girl and got married during that time
and I also lost my manager of 10 years
during that time as well and and the
song the title track things that we
drink to is actually about that but it's
just a way of celebrating the life of
someone that you lost rather than kind
of I guess a celebration as a way of
mourning if that makes sense but yeah
dude it's funny I am when I was putting
this the tracklist for the album
together I realized that they all have
some sort of drinking metaphor as I go
okay well that's gonna be the title
though yeah well I mean I think about
Bay Drive right and I think about the
video the day drunk which is amazing can
you tell me about shaking that how you
chose to go where you were going like
what was that all of that man I I wanted
to challenge myself creatively on the
videos on this reckless Oh for kiss
somebody we did like this one shot that
slowed down like a 15 second shot that
was the whole video yeah but took all
day to shoot
yeah and for this one we did it in
Reverse so I had to learn the song
day-drunk in Reverse which I think it's
like not the ad in Norway that's really
good yeah we need a drunk okay you can
put this in Reverse now and hopefully it
looks like that but did it was one of
the hottest things I've ever done yeah
yeah I mean it was really difficult to
learn but then also to do all that stuff
in the video whilst remembering yeah it
was challenging but I feel like the
energy of it sort of matches the song
with school so this isn't all just this
is not just for jokes for you you like
you like to challenge yourself when it
comes to not just the videos but putting
the music together like everything right
yeah I mean there's so many people if
there's one thing I learned getting to
Nashville was that look how good
everyone is yeah you know it's a it's
it's one of those towns that can inspire
you and intimidate you all within the
course of one day and
it makes you want to be better at the
best of times and so yeah I'm I'm always
trying to trying to reach for whatever
that next thing is
so when you and Kelsey are date drinking
what is your drink of choice we we love
tequila man we bonded over tequila we
sort of we met hosting an award show in
Australia and and after the award show
was the kind of a celebration shot that
may have led to two or three and so yeah
it's kind of it's been a thing in our
relationship and I'm totally cool with
that nice I think that's a good drink of
choice that's actually my drink of
choice to you man yeah just for that
Cheers
all right so tell me about this whole
tour that you're doing with Rascal
Flatts I mean this is this is a huge
deal when they call you up is there any
question that you're gonna then you're
doing this thing no not for me yeah I
don't know how many questions I yeah no
I mean I'm such a big Rascal Flatts fan
and have been I mean you just have to
watch the show it's like classics of the
last almost 20 years and also to get to
go play all these places as well I
haven't played in Toronto before and
yeah this place is beautiful and huge
and there's so many kind of aspects to
why it's so great to be out here but
it's been an amazing summer and yeah
it's coming to the end this week with
these guys but this feels like the right
way to see it out yeah I try on the
crowd is a special crowd you'll have a
great yeah they really appreciate the
music hello and you're gonna become a
vet cancer when you're doing your your
next big tour right we are yes we just
um we just started a world tour and we
just did in the last 10 days we did
Glatt Dublin Ireland Glasgow Scotland
Liverpool London and lots of Worth
England go in and then we flew straight
from Berlin Germany to Toronto and if
I'm saying anything ridiculous that's
why but you know we're continuing that
to Australia next month and then the
following month we're doing the United
States and coming up to the other side
of this
beautiful country for the first time
ever that's amazing just make sure that
when you get out there you do say
Toronto like that you don't say the
wrong city right you don't know where
you're at right now I haven't done that
before I don't think I've seen it on
movies though Yeah right on the back
your guitar yeah I should write it on my
set list or something like that yeah
Toronto yeah it is yeah so considering
you and Kelsey like I don't know
you sound so good together is there a
desert a duet album maybe in our future
in your future man I think I'd be really
fun to do one day yeah we're definitely
both doing our own thing right now and I
sort of each other's biggest fans and
cheerleaders and all that kind of thing
so we'll keep it that for a little while
yet but I don't see why not
you